[Music]
Europa the icy moon of
Jupiter a frigid world that would turn
you into an astronaut
popsicle and an atmosphere that would
take your breath away literally because
europ is at atmosphere is so thin it's
almost
non-existent and while it's mostly made
up of oxygen this oxygen isn't
breathable for you you just wouldn't be
able to inhale it in this extremely low
pressure environment and this Frozen
world has a dark
secret deep under its thick crust of ice
it might just hide
life that's why we're sending a member
of our team on on a mission to explore
Europa and find out if anything can
survive in this unforgiving environment
Chase we need you on this one-way trip
to Jupiter's neighborhood Mission
Control this is Chase orbiting Europa
and ready for landing did you know it
would actually take you like 6 years to
get here from Earth but luckily I'm
already here and I love finding new
alien buddies when they're not trying to
kill me all right Chase initiate the
landing sequence already on it Rico
start the landing sequence I totally
forgot Landing sequence
[Music]
initiated 500 M and
descending 400
m
touchdown all that's right as Sprite oh
my
eyeballs that's strange Europa is five
times farther from the Sun than Earth
and gets much less sunlight than we do
it must be so bright because of europa's
icy surface all that ice is highly
reflective that plus an almost absent
atmosphere could make the light feel
very harsh so just use the protective
tint advisor and your eyes will be fine
Chase what's your status yeah I'd say
Europa is pretty similar to Earth if
Earth had no atmosphere was covered in
ice and had absolutely no interesting
oceans to see so in short it sucks what
if guy I'm freezing out here yeah you'd
need an advanced thermal insulation
layer in your suit to keep you warm the
surface temperature on Europa is about
-45° C and it can get as cold as -
220°
c it's also bathed in radiation that's
because you're Europa orbits so close to
Jupiter and Jupiter has a massive
magnetic field that traps a lot of high
energy particles inside it your space
suit would need to be able to withstand
that too
great Europa is one of the four largest
moons of Jupiter it's still slightly
smaller than our moon but it's a lot
more exciting mainly because it has the
potential to host life looks pretty
lifeless if you ask me well it is on the
surface look life needs three
ingredients to exist on any world the
first one is liquid water well Europa
has plenty of that NASA's Galileo
spacecraft which spent 8 years orbiting
Jupiter gathered some data on Europa too
and that data LED scientists to believe
that this moon has twice as much water
as all of Earth's oceans well I regret
to report that your scientist data is
wrong I don't see no water only ice this
mission is a waste of my precious time
no no no it isn't you don't see them
because these enormous oceans aren't on
the surface they're deep below europa's
thick icy
crust that brings us to another
ingredient for Life Energy on Earth life
mostly gets energy from the Sun but
that's not the case on Europa first of
all because Europa is so far away from
the Sun and second L because if there is
life on Europa it's likely we'd find it
under the ice where there's no sunlight
at all Europa gets its energy from the
effects of tidal Heating and it has
Jupiter to thank for that yeah the
enormous gravity of the Solar System's
biggest planet is constantly pulling on
Europa bulging and cracking its ice this
causes friction and the friction Heats
this moon from the inside
that's why europa's subsurface ocean
doesn't freeze over like the rest of
this frigid World Europa might also have
hydrothermal vents on its ocean floor
just like Earth does these vents spew
out heat energy and chemicals
potentially creating a habitable
environment around
them the last ingredient for life is
chemical elements most living things are
made up of stuff like carbon hydrogen
nitrogen ox oxygen phosphorus and sulfur
and based on the data we collected about
Europa this Moon's got all that but of
course no one has ever been on Europa to
confirm this until now uh and and what
that yeah those are europa's famous cryo
volcanoes these volcanoes don't erupt
with lava but with water and ice ice
volcanoes that's sick oh my God okay
okay so how do you suggest I find life
here this ice looks thick yeah you'd
have to drill through it and you'd need
special equipment like a high
performance drill designed for extreme
cold electrically powered by a portable
nuclear generator lightweight with a
heating mechanism and a sample retrieval
system right great so just like the
everyday stuff that you would just
happen to carry around with you on your
spaceship no I'm serious I haven't have
that on my spaceship I have the best
drill in Universe I'm so excited to meet
Who's down here oh hold on the chances
of seeing any kind of life with your own
eyes are slim because that life if it
exists is likely
microscopic but if you get a sample of
that salty water well you can examine it
and maybe find traces of
microorganisms that's not how I picture
this Mission but well since we're here
let's do
[Music]
this while you can't improve the odds of
seeing aliens on Europa you can increase
the opportunity of seeing more of
Chase's Epic Adventures on what if we've
already traveled with them to Titan
Venus even Uranus and there's so much
more we want to show you that's why we
launched our what if Explorers Club on
patreon that's where we give you the top
secret behind the scenes extended
director Cuts mind-blowing art epic
merch discounts and Our Endless Love and
gratitude report us on patreon to get
exclusive content and help us send Chase
to his death over and over and over
again
hey I don't feel so
good I think it might puke your body
temperature is rising you're
experiencing the symptoms of radiation
poisoning I did warn you that radiation
levels on Europa are high even in your
space suit you'd still feel headaches
nausea dizziness all the fun that comes
from radiation sickness and all that
after spending only a few hours on this
Moon if you don't return to your
shielded spacecraft immediately this
exposure will kill you huh oh no no I'm
might fine now I'm good Rico you I just
need to lie down for 5 minutes just
that's a bad idea you need to return the
samples to the spaceship right the
samples I have to get the samp supp
[Music]
this this is still so sick
though the impact force from the cryo
volcano has damaged your space suit
you're losing
oxygen I should have subscribe to the
top tier of what have
patreon
in the extreme conditions of Europa
without the full protection of a suit
you'd only have a few minutes to get to
Safety in just 1 minute severe frostbite
would damage your Exposed Skin after 2
minutes you'd start shivering Q
hypothermia another 10 minutes later and
you'd lose Consciousness and freeze to
death oh wait scratch all that looks
like Chase's suit lost loost all the
oxygen and he just
suffocated now we'll never know if those
samples had any life in
them yeah we'll have to try this search
for life again maybe next time Chase can
set up a base first before going out
there and exploring
things but that's a story for another
what
[Music]
if